welcome to this video on play l Kaiser
Kaiser from Mexico ok mums playing some
sort of Dutch Dutch defense with
deficient 2d6 yeah what D 5 is the
general argument against the solid set
up when the bishop is on e 7 and I'm not
sure that this is a big difference hmm
ok well now let's just complete
development here mmm do I go night to be
five here probably has special you five
now 94 is also an idea for black hmm ok
I'm not sure how how great this is but I
need to get going membership form maybe
get rid of the a5 bishop
yeah okay this is a double point but i'm
not sure how how bad it is okay um I
don't have any tactic here rides know
why I guess I just need to retreat might
take now maybe just keep it simple and
take now yeah I have night at five but
he can squint e6 taking this night okay
let's just just keep it simple he takes
with the palm I have knight c6 285 and
here ok f4 hang some that's that's not
good okay I need to tell therefore I
guess yeah that's not not very much that
white has him if at all anything okay
it's a it's solid i can try to to to
work with that you probably can just
take here or play g6 least i'm not far
behind on the clock
taking his time anything great that I
can do him that I'm not seeing I mean
just taking should be all right he has
no serious weakness on g6 I mean that's
we had was he taking that long I mean
okay Wow why I was this is a move
putting the Knights all the way back how
to hard to comprehend can you play here
okay and don't don't know what what this
move is all about
I mean this night is not like killing
him or something but 98 I wouldn't have
thought of okay it was them
you know maybe you will just take a gym
I can take only six I don't have any of
any great follow-up to that really be
fitted I can tell also get this check
and tick on a five if I this is just
just complicated but ok I really don't
mind that much if he takes down even
this is quite quite ok I have the double
porn but the knight on d5 is just very
dominant they cannot play the C porn as
b6 hangs and I have rook e1 and
strengthening moves the doubled point is
not a big issue
and you're not quite sure how he should
defend now I also to get with the king
of King of three moves like this okay
try to be try to be quick okay i can
give the trick which does not really
promise much i guess so don't you just
just go back Ruby aid was probably a
good good defense f5 c5 and 94 maybe
on rookie 7 eos hasbrouck f7 this is not
really leading to very much
what to see you thinking about okay
going here take stakes I would have a
ticket for Hanks so I understand but
probably Kings b3 rope tonight xe5 is
not any good maybe this intending f3
clicking the night back and maybe night
to be six
Jan I'd be 695 probably but if I don't
go there in place 95 even before that
Wow ok
don't see how he defends this now okay
this way if I take cookie too
yeah probably so still should take Jack
and try to to be quick with the sea porn
check see pollicis is quick 97 okay it's
got this chick here time morning check
mmm this is a perpetual rod it really is
that's not good okay hoops III maybe I
have 97 c 8 anyway right so I can have a
3d 4d for up to three this I'm still
winning our night is seven and chg
cannot cannot prevent probably this is
so not the easiest way to do it Jack but
it's it's enough i believe check check
check
check so really he wants to play this on
check check check me what Queen deform
this is less precise I was close to do
that okay yeah this was sir not very
convincing I guess hmm a three thought
that this end game would be much better
than it actually was rook b8 is a good
news who be 8 and c6 looks ugly but it's
effective yeah if I if I have to retreat
this night then I really don't have
anything here I mean I of course I tried
but there is nothing nothing going on 94
is probably good and this is this is a
Anna Bishop smooth maybe look at sixes
interesting here Brooke f6 mm-hmm this
is ok for black I cannot really play f3
here jack
yeah this is this is a very nice obscene
to f4 and on this would have been good
that's what have been good yeah this is
a bit risky this decentralization is
it's really risky and after this I'm
probably almost winning here the id-5
was a mistake he can just play any group
d 8 or something you know this cannot be
really great I mean he's got this
possibility also just to trade this off
and get to Luke and Kim yeah and it
should be ok but here I'm just getting
the pawn yeah and I think this should be
a win in the long run I mean not in the
long run but I mean without calculating
I thought it is a winner than it should
be yeah nitey force is immediately
giving giving the sea porn yeah allowing
the sea pondered Pro Mode and 98 is a
bit tougher but ok this this is winning
with the sea poll ok thanks for watching